trouve Nicolas Tenzer politologue
enseignant à Sciences Po spécialiste des
questions stratégiques et
internationales auteur de l'ouvrage le
monde à l'horizon 2030 la règle et le
désordre bonjour pour le moment l'OTAN
sort renforcé de l'invasion russe en
Ukraine mais il n'y a toujours pas de
perspective de paix en Ukraine non
effectivement il n'y a pas de
perspective de paix parce que de toute
manière comme le secrétaire d'État
américain Antony blinkel la rappeler
comme Emmanuel Macron l'a rappelé il y a
également deux jours à Bratislava à une
conférence à laquelle j'étais il ne peut
pas y avoir de conflits gelés il ne peut
pas y avoir de territoire non récupérés
par l'Ukraine c'est totalement
impossible et je trouve que là dessus
vous avez une très forte convergence
entre la France et les États-Unis il
n'est pas question de faire la paix tant
que une partie du territoire
ukrainien est occupé ça je crois que
c'est très important deuxièmement
renforcer le temps oui avec l'adhésion
de la Finlande bientôt de la Suède en
revanche on peut constater que le
secrétaire d'État était muet sur les
perspectives d'adhésion de l'Ukraine et
de la Moldavie lors du sommet de Vilnius
prévu les 11 et 12 juillet c'est quelque
chose qu'attendent les Ukrainiens
j'étais moi-même il y a une semaine à
kif j'ai pu le constater c'est l'heure
qui est une majeur il faut absolument
leur apporter des garanties de sécurité
jusqu'à présent même s'il peut y en
avoir d'autres l'adhésion possible à
l'OTAN constitue la meilleure d'ailleurs
Emmanuel Macron lui aussi a pratiqué
avant si je peux faire de nouveau ce
parallèle à constaté qu'il n'y avait pas
d'unanimité même si on sent que le
président français en fait verrait de
manière favorable un même marché
d'action plan c'est à dire un plan
d'adhésion à l'OTAN accordé à l'Ukraine
on va y revenir mais s'il y a pas de
victoire militaire sur le terrain c'est
une guerre sans fin
oui c'est à dire que c'est une guerre
sans fin c'est pour ça qu'il est très
important de donner tous les moyens à
l'Ukraine pour se défendre c'est pour ça
que prochainement des F-16 américains
mais fournis par d'autres pays que les
États-Unis devraient être livrés à
l'Ukraine il y a de plus en vrai ça ce
sera sans doute en septembre-octobre il
y aura également des armes à plus
longues portées qui vont être donnés
mais on doit constater malheureusement
que les Alliés surtout d'ailleurs les
américains restent encore alors que ça a
été répété depuis 8 mois 10 mois par
mois par d'autres également en quelque
sorte à mi-chem aujourd'hui il faut
vraiment donner tous les moyens à
l'Ukraine de se défendre de récupérer
l'ensemble des territoires conquis sinon
effectivement la perspective que vous
évoquez et bien celle d'une guerre sans
fin ça veut dire des dizaines des
centaines des milliers plus
vraisemblablement de morts réguliers du
côté ukrainien mais les américains ils
insistent beaucoup
sa livraison d'armes américaines ne doit
pas être utilisé sur le territoire russe
qu'en serait-il aujourd'hui si l'Ukraine
était membre de l'OTAN était au sein de
l'OTAN alors je pense que il y a un
article essentiel qu'il faut rappeler à
nos affaires américains qui connaissent
quand même qui est l'article 51 de la
Charte des Nations Unies celui-ci dit
qu'un pays agressé peut riposter contre
l'agresseur par tous les moyens y
compris en visant des phrases des bases
aériennes militaires ou des sites
d'approvisionnement logistique sur le
territoire du Pays agresseur et qu'un
État qui viendrait se porter au secours
du pays agressé ce qui est le cas pour
les pays qui aident l'Ukraine pourrait
parfaitement d'ailleurs eux-mêmes ou
avec leurs armes frapper ce territoire
on sent encore cette prudence on sent
cette réticence et je trouve que
aujourd'hui c'est dans quelque chose
dommageable c'est-à-dire que si on
considère vraiment avec sérieux cette
guerre et je trouve que les mots du
secrétaire d'État américain Anthony
blinken ont été très forts au début de
discours quand il a comparé la situation
d'aujourd'hui à celle de 1939 d'ailleurs
c'est pas une référence à la guerre
froide mais c'est bien une guerre
d'agression celle par l'Allemagne nazie
et ses alliés je crois véritablement
aller jusqu'au bout je pense que si
l'Ukraine devenait membre de l'OTAN ce
que je souhaite et bien il faudrait
qu'elle soit complètement protégées
d'ailleurs on constate là aussi je fais
de nouveau références au discours
d'Emmanuel Macron il y a deux jours à
Bratislava il a dit qu'il fallait donner
à l'Ukraine des garanties de sécurité
soit dans un cadre bilatéral soit dans
un cadre multilatéral et pourquoi ne pas
faire ce que je suggère depuis quelques
temps dès aujourd'hui c'est à dire
envoyer qu'il y ait adhésion ou non de
l'Ukraine immédiate de l'OTAN des
troupes de l'OTAN ou des troupes
européennes ça peut se faire dans le
cadre de l'UE aussi sur le sol ukrainien
en tout cas sur tout le territoire qui a
déjà été reconquis par l'Ukraine et la
partie qui le sera prochainement donc il
y aura aucune négociation avec les
Russes aucune négociation pour une paix
durable si l'Ukraine a d'ailleurs
voilà je pense pas mais c'est pas encore
une fois le prétexte de l'OTAN qui est
une alliance défensive ça a été rappelé
partenaire blinken je dirais de toute
manière il ne peut pas y avoir de paix
avec un régime agresseur un régime qui a
des crimes contre l'humanité crime de
génocide crime d'agression crime de
guerre bien sûr aussi depuis plus de 22
ans d'abord en Tchétchénie en Géorgie en
Syrie en Ukraine en Afrique enfin on met
dans un état on a un en face d'un étang
qui représente le sommet de l'agression
donc faire la paix avec cet état
d'ailleurs c'était implicite dans le
discours de blinken ce serait une faute
enfin en tout cas tant qu'il n'y a pas
de changement de régime à Moscou et ça
on le sait ça prendra un certain temps
et vous pensez que si un changement de
résine ceux qui vont remplacer Vladimir
Poutine seront forcément mieux
pas dans l'immédiat nécessairement mais
c'est pour ça que c'est une transition
qu'il faut avoir un plan stratégique
vis-à-vis de la Russie de notre côté
quand européen côté américain sur les
prochaines années ménager une transition
ne pas lâcher sur les sanctions même
lorsque la Russie sera défaite en
Ukraine et exercer des pressions
continues sur le sur le régime et dans
l'immédiat bien sûr protéger les pays
qui sont aujourd'hui agressés par la
Russie que ce soit l'Ukraine la Géorgie
vous avez encore 20% du territoire
conquis un gouvernement pro russe
soutenu par Moscou le Belarus avec des
troupes russes déployés sur le sol de ce
régime qui est par ailleurs un régime
criminel voyez également les menaces sur
la Moldavie le sommeil de la CPE
communauté politique européenne s'est
réunir à chicinaux d'ailleurs à porter
un soutien à la Moldavie voyez les
exactions du trouble vague du groupe
Wagner en Afrique vous voyez les crimes
qui continuent de la part de la Russie
en Syrie je pense qu'il faut avoir cette
vision de long terme que si j'ai pas
uniquement de l'U kraine même si
l'urgence immédiate mais véritablement
comment mettre la Russie hors d'état de
nuire et de tuer une série de peuples ou
de les emprisonner ou de les laisser
dans une situation d'agression et de
pression vous parlez justement d'un
régime criminel on sait que dans les
démocraties l'arme nucléaire c'est une
dissuasion or vous l'avez dit la Russie
n'est pas une démocratie c'est pas
l'opinion russe qui va freiner la main
de Vladimir Poutine
bien sûr malheureusement effectivement
parce que il faut voir aussi que même si
vous avez une petite partie de l'opinion
qui proteste qui est malheureusement
pour une grande partie songeons à
Vladimir caramos
qui sont en prison aujourd'hui d'autres
sont condamnés à l'exil ce n'est pas
l'opinion bien sûr qu'il peut le faire
de toute manière je pense qu'il y a
aussi une grande partie de cette opinion
qui malheureusement
est en quelque sorte résignée depuis si
nombreuses années à vivre dans dans
l'oppression donc c'est quelque chose
encore une fois qui va falloir
ménager dans dans l'avenir sur la menace
nucléaire que vous évoquez je crois que
bien sûr il faut la prendre au sérieux
mais il ne faut pas non plus je dirais
se dire que on va reculer devant il va
falloir céder il va falloir négocier à
cause de cette menace nucléaire sinon
effectivement s'en est fini
véritablement des principes de nos
démocratie et ce serait aussi un mauvais
exemple qu'on donnerait à d'autres
puissances menaçantes comme la Chine sur
Taïwan notamment et ça ce serait une
très mauvais e chose je crois qu'il y a
toute une partie de la propagande russe
depuis très longtemps et Poutine a été
le premier à le faire bien avant le
déclenchement de la guerre en Ukraine
qui agite la menace nucléaire pour
espérer que les démocraties ne
réagissent pas et c'est vrai pendant 22
ans ça a marché pendant 22 ans Poutine
en quelque sorte à gagner toutes ses
guerres et ce n'est que depuis le 24
février 2022 qu'en fin en quelque sorte
les démocratie on résolu vraiment de
réagir de s'unir et ça c'est déjà une
très bonne chose merci beaucoup Nicolas
Tenzer pour votre analyse en direct sur
France 24 merci à vous